well welcome everyone this afternoon
to the fourth and final lecture in John
Dunn's series of Stimson lectures beyond
the democratic maze I see some faces who
have been here before and some who have
not so those of you who are joining us
toward the the end you'll have to get
the full story from the book which will
be published by Yale University Press
next year when we hope that's a
statement of hope perhaps not optimism
but we're certainly all looking forward
to it the in these lectures Don has
given us a fascinating account of the
democracy as on the one hand a world
historical idea and on the other hand
it's improbable connection with other
ideas that make it's the reasons for its
world historical force extremely
difficult to pin down in yesterday's
lecture he talked a lot about the mutual
incomprehension between American
perceptions of American democracy and
perceptions of others most notably of
American democracy but then also of very
different kinds of democracies that have
been ascendant in recent times most
notably the very improbable democratic
political system in India and he had in
the course of that discussion of he
introduced a fascinating idea of
democracy as a self indigenized concept
that email men have may or may not have
more to say about today but certainly he
was giving us a a magnifying glass to
look at what he described as -
democracy's disorientation and I think
succeeded and to some extent we were all
somewhat disoriented as a result
of that experience but never fear
because today he's going to tell us how
to recover our bearings the lecture is
called recovering our bearings
fatalities choice and comprehension John
Donne thank you very much in soldiered
through being here again we all need
Haven as perhaps especially in this
instance yeah the University Press what
really matters about political ideas is
what happens to them in political news
what happens through them
I've been trying in these lectures to
share how far we are present from
understanding what has been happening
through the idea of democracy over the
last three quarters of a century and why
that now matters as much as it does
that's what listening for in this last
lecture there's less about fatalities
than I thought I was going to put in
maybe we'll have to try and use hope
instead choice and comprehension ought
to go fairly happily with hope obviously
is more Dantean in style if democracy as
we currently understand it did reliably
clarify political choices and if it
orientated human populations dependably
in their array of existential and
biological settings by doing so we would
know by now after more than six decades
whether indian democracy had proved to
be a good idea or instead a strike only
bad a one idea and even if many of us
for one reason
or another were still impeded in
recognizing the answer to that question
we can be very confident that the great
majority of India's own population would
be emphatically confident of what in
years
as it happens there's by now
surprisingly good reason to believe that
the latter is in fact true and that the
answer is positive less than emphatic in
confidence some of the blemishes in
India's democracy have long been obvious
enough the speed and insouciance with
which Indira Gandhi's emergency was
imposed the continuing degradation of
the living conditions and personal
treatment of large segments of the
untouchables and tribals the openly
cynical logrolling which dominates so
much of its routine politics the
flagrant corruption of a state apparatus
infinitely opened on all to many
channels to malignant intelligence
energy and initiative the clear
deterioration in intellectual and moral
quality of India's political class not
all of these are kosher political
science terms but people who are
interested in India well they're that
they apply and it's increasingly rampant
criminality at the criminality of that
class so spectacularly at odds with the
presuppositions of constitutional
democracy the continuing brutality of
its police force and often of its
military practices in local repression
and the state's severely limited
efficacy in policing itself
unsurprisingly the blemishes in India's
democracy are at least as easy to
identify from inside India as they could
be from the outside but viewed from
inside India they merge indiscernibly
with the substance of India itself as
the idea of democracy if it's not to be
a travesty in the last instance requires
that it must
democracy might have been a good or a
bad idea
for India when it won its independence
but India itself was neither a good nor
a bad idea but by now I readily concede
you couldn't say confidently still say
exactly the same for Pakistan which was
quite a definite political idea at that
time and hasn't since warned very well
as such but India itself at that point
can't illuminating lis be said to have
been an idea at all rather like every
human society it was a palimpsest of
historical achievement failure and
mishap and an unfathomable human
predicament amongst the questions which
faced its inhabitants at that point was
whether or not to become a
constitutional democracy
it's from the subsequent fortunes of its
answer to that question that the world
as a whole can now learn something fresh
and potentially dramatic about what
democracy does and does not imply some
of what can be inferred from India over
that time span of course that could
perfectly well be learnt from elsewhere
you can readily infer from most
protracted experiences of representative
democracy in action in capitalist
settings that the formal political
equality which democracy promises and
purports to guarantee is fully
compatible with perpetuating extreme
inequality and vast in justices and even
those inured to the scale of each in
their own society may still be shocked
by the heterogeneity and extremity of
India's variations on that ancient human
theme more interestingly perhaps if just
continuously and sometimes
disconcertingly you can also learn that
the workings of constitutional democracy
over many decades can in due course
prove quite an effective and
ingratiating palliative even to huge and
deeply historic
entrenched injustice more pressingly
still you can learn that the long slow
erratic and ungainly recognition and
amendment of historically very profound
injustice is a clearly superior
alternative to political projects of a
raising extreme injustice by frontal
assault like the killing fields of the
Khmer Rouge a lesson are still pertinent
to large areas of India's countryside
you can also draw more positive and
enlivening inferences from the same
experience if democracy almost certainly
won't over any time horizon eliminate
extreme inequality and evident in
justice from a capitalist world to which
we have no sane alternative we now know
that it can be installed and durably
sustained with you historical luck even
in vast and miserably poor societies on
as large a scale as human political
ideas have yet been tried out extreme
poverty doesn't preclude democracy more
ever once it has been installed and for
as long as it can be sustained as a
macho CERN as long insisted it can lift
a millennial II grim threat from human
populations the threat of famine and
mass starvation because of the male
distribution of potentially available
food resources
what Bengal meant for the first half of
the 20th century and Ireland for the
century before and what China
alas meant for countless millions of its
own citizens
well after India's independence no
democratic polity need ever mean again
we shouldn't exaggerate the scope of
that apparent finding it's still unclear
how far it rests on the structure of
political authority itself and how far
it's issued from the continuing
independence from governmental control
of India's newspaper press an economic
outcome
as much as a legally guaranteed status
an economic outcome scarcely in practice
insured by the dynamics of any
capitalist economy but even read with
due caution and qualification the record
of India's Democratic experience is both
a luminous demonstration of what it is
about this elusive idea which has given
it such remarkable historical impetus
over the last two centuries and ringing
vindication of its capacity to benefit
the human populations which take it up
it's still though as essential as ever
not to mistake what that capacity
implies to perform well over time a
political order has above all to master
and sustain Authority and to direct the
judgment of those who hold it to act
effectively for the better not all human
populations are in a position to do that
within any conceivable political
framework nothing at this point can be
offered in good faith to the suffering
people of Somalia still less effectively
provided which could predictably serve
them for those purposes and it seems
that best unlikely that any one has yet
seen how to provide it to the
inhabitants of Afghanistan or the
Democratic Republic of the Congo or the
bitterly divided population of Libya
history can be brutal to human
populations and it not infrequently
still unmistakably is in a much wider
range of settings than any one in
particular seriously surmised three
centuries ago democracy invariance of
its modern format may well be accessible
through resources historically available
to the societies which are already there
but it is no magical device to conjure
up those resources way that where they
are grimly absent
the dilemmas of liberal imperialism
haven't faded from the world a richer
better armed and technically more
advanced society is far from guaranteed
to prove a kinder or more discerning one
democracy has not proved a dependable
heuristic for a latent normative order
in any historical Society of which we
know even if there is such an order
there to discern in the first place the
experience of India confirms this less
than startling finding as amply as that
of the United States or France Britain
or Germany Ireland or Greece but however
undependable the mechanism it remains
for judging what in the end to do in
India as everywhere else
India's independent experience has
established as buoyantly as America's
did in the eyes of Tocqueville
democracy's unique dynamism as heuristic
for the full range of social purpose
sentiment and aspiration present in it
democracy has given rise to and
fermented the seething biological
vitality and the insistent proliferation
of India's efflorescence civil society
often without lending it much purchase
on the content or outcomes of state
decisions but obstructing a very great
deal of what that state would otherwise
have had a mind to do and opening up the
penetrator of India's bewilderingly
complex society in a way no previous
epoch in Indian history could
conceivably have tried to on the great
issues of Destiny confronting the
world's human population today that
swirling and fractious disorder may
still sometimes Harbor within it besides
a great deal else
sounder judgments than the current
consensus of the boards of
multinational extractive industries and
energy suppliers or even the Harris
custodians of public budgets that too is
part of democracy's disorientation and
we have yet to identify a promising
approach to distinguishing its widening
sensitization of our collective judgment
to what we need to recognize and learn
to take account of from it's evident
propensity to weaken and the musa
thority and imperil the capacity of
those who precariously hold it to reach
stable judgments on many of the most
drastic challenges facing us or convince
their fellow citizens of the urgency of
the judgments they have reached once
they contrived to the issue of how to
judge well together that ancient Greek
issue remains as fundamental as ever in
human collective life and we've made
remarkably little secure progress in
recognizing why we would continue to do
it so erratically why the judgments
which govern our most consequential
collective actions on the largest scale
on which we can yet decide to act often
still contrive to have such calamitous
consequences why and this is implied but
there we go why did the people of the
United States still squander such a will
dream proportion of their incomes on
spectacularly inefficient provision for
the health of most of their number or
find it so impossible to discipline
their energy consumption to promise
their children or grandchildren unless
evidently dangerous and profligate
future all of those questions of course
have well-formed answers tailored to fit
a variety of tastes as well as interests
of course some of them worked out with
great professional care and ingenuity in
this town in Reis
years what matters for my purposes is
what it is about democracy as an idea
which means that however carefully and
cogently those answers are worked out
no one can rationally be confident that
their discovery will transform the
outcomes in the political world and all
that too is part of democracy's
disorientation the degree to which it
confuses our efforts to judge
collectively and the intimidating impact
of the consequences of that conclusion
on our disposition even to try to where
human populations the population knows
just where it is from its own point of
view and can see just what it has to
choose about there's nothing about
democracy which ensures that it will
disorientate that population or impair
their capacity to make up their minds
and act accordingly arguably in many
ways and for quite a long time
the DeMoss of athens found themselves in
that happy position and it's certainly
possible to tell the political history
of the United States or Britain or
France or the Federal Republic of
Germany over carefully chosen periods
says that their populations to come out
are steadily orientated through those
institutions and correspondingly
equipped to decide democratically to act
as they have good reason to but to tell
the story of any community in those
terms you have to pick your dates with
some care not to start too early or
carry on too long and even then it can
never be right to attribute the felicity
in orientation to the mode in which they
took their decisions that Felicity has
to be there in the structure of their
collective lives and the antecedent
clarity and in some sense validity of
their current judgments as a mechanism
of decision democracy itself can never
provide
that orientation the best it registers
and enacts an orientation which is
already there where there is no such
reasonably convergent orientation no
clear common interest you might say what
emerges from democratic decision is
either contingent confusion or at best a
lucky fluke that's a very old-fashioned
way of thinking and conspicuously
politically incorrect but it's central
to my argument that newer fashions have
been ill-advised to shrug it aside it
certainly doesn't mean that any aspiring
autocrat will prove a good bet still
less that autocracy as such is a bet
with any merit at all it merely means
that the world of politics remains a
very dangerous place and that we've been
exceedingly foolish to see democracy's
recent advance as an effective way to
remove those dangers or even a secure
guarantee of diminishing any of them
which are compatible with its coming
into existence in the first place
there's something powerful and inspiring
about democracy's passage through modern
world history something about the ideas
which the term in its transmission
between languages has conjured up which
is strength and Myriad's of grievously
oppressed human beings in the face of
the pain and suffering meted out to them
by those who rule or exploit them that
strengthening has made democracy a
source of power as well as a vector of
power but that reinforcement has also
conspicuously failed to render it a
particularly helpful guide to what any
human population is well advised to do
that admittedly Curt judgment profanes
one of the century the principal deities
of many of today's societies but it
doesn't clash with the bulk of political
experience over time in any society
- at all and there's little reason to
anticipate it's coming to do so anywhere
in the future why should such a
commonplace observation have come to
seem so profane part of what's made its
answer is a shift in the meaning of the
term over the last century and a half
which I alluded to at the beginning of
my first lecture no speaker of classical
Greek of whom we are aware understood
the term démocratie
as a synonym for good government there
many Greeks certainly favored democracy
in their census the form of government
for their own policies and often for
other police too but in the political
speech of increasingly many countries
across the world today and this one most
obtrusively and consequentially of all
democracy has come often to be heard and
meant precisely as good government not
in the sense of government with reliably
desirable consequences where the
equation would indeed be bizarre enough
to be barely intelligible but in the
sense of government exercised on a
wholly appropriate basis and through
unimpeachable means government fully
sanctioned by the people and exerted in
the spirit and through the means which
the latter have explicitly chosen or if
they happen not as yet to have disclosed
their choice through means they would
definitely welcome heard like that
democracy is unmistakeably a critical
category and one usually at some
distance from the existing dispersion of
opinion amongst the population at large
but democracy is also and in the speech
of just the same people the conventional
term for the political order through
which they find themselves ruled and
which all too frequently conflicts
agonizingly with many of their most
urgent purposes and deepest commitments
a term which equivocates in that way
between an authoritative
standard of right conduct and the
practical character of an existing
regime is a ready source of confusion
even for those professionally dedicated
to keeping their own thinking and speech
clear in active use in the
rough-and-tumble of political life it's
all but certain to confuse a great many
is American government today so confused
so fractious and so dysfunctional
despite democracy or because of
democracy you can make the case either
way depending on how you happen to hear
the term what you can't readily hope to
do is remove either the confusion the
fractious honest or the dysfunctionality
by establishing the superior credentials
of your own terminological choice so the
political question of who or what
exactly is responsible for the confusion
fractious nasur dysfunctionality is left
untouched by the terminological quarrel
but the fractious 'no sit self is
further exacerbated by the sense that
your political opponents must be either
confused or dishonest as well as well as
already adhesively in the wrong it isn't
hard to see how that confusion has
arisen the core presumption and central
political appeal of the form of
government we now eventually call
democracy is that it embodies or at
least seeks to realize a way of reaching
political decisions which is fair to
every citizen because it treats each
equally the symbolic form of that
commitment today is the notionally equal
vote equal not merely in entitlement but
also in its prospective causal efficacy
that's certainly a better symbol than no
vote at all or votes which are
explicitly weighed unequally on one
ground or another but that notionally
equal vote enters fleetingly and at very
lengthy intervals a dense domain of very
active causality little of any of which
is discernibly structured through any
mode of equality at all and which is
consequently reshaped in any discernable
way by that entry very little more
frequently and usually to nugatory
effect expressed abstractly enough equal
votes remain a more plausible proxy for
a fair basis on which for a human
grouping to take the decisions it must
than any rival of comparable existential
immediacy or imaginative intelligibility
but any modern state at all let alone a
state on the scale of the USA
continuously makes and struggles to
enforce a stunning number of decisions
all of them in conditions of great prior
determinacy the decisions its citizens
take when they cast their votes
disappear into that endless bedlam of
largely frustrated exertion with
startling rapidity and often almost
without trace at the level of outcome
neither the decisions which are in fact
in the end taken and nor the basis on
which they in fact have been decided nor
even the competing frameworks of
assessment which furnish their most
potent contributors with their grounds
and justifications for a meanness they
have carry through with any clarity or
directness to those on whose behalf
they're being taken and who between them
must presumptively have authorized such
decisions to be taken in their name the
result certainly feels like being ruled
as it blamele is if on a somewhat
inscrutable basis what it never feels
like an equally plainly isn't is ruling
by turns the presumption of
authorization
isn't just a polite fiction as it
plausibly still is in China and
certainly appeared to be in Egypt under
the presidency of Mubarak certainly is
blight and it very largely is a fiction
but it's a polite fiction with weighty
consequences some of those consequences
admittedly stem from the respect in
which it isn't a fiction at all they
arise from the impact of the point of
affirming it on the incentives of the
politicians who choose to and they give
the best grounds for regarding it as an
appropriate label for the form of
government in question what is decisive
there is the direction of causality
where the politicians grounds for acting
as they do are the known prior choices
of the majority of the dimas and the
political rewards they anticipate from
being seen to implement those choices
democracy is an impeccable name for the
basis on which the decisions are in fact
taken but in those cases there's no
practical disparity between the
Democratic selection of the politicians
in question and the Democratic choice of
the outcome over most of the field of
representative democracy in action and
especially over that very large
proportion of that field which is
largely impervious to the interventions
of elected politicians there's no such
causal sequence to be traced what
happens may happen under the more
democracy's auspices but it doesn't
happen because of anything which
democracy intelligibly or perceptibly
implies it simply does not arise
predictably from the incentive structure
of iterative electoral choice but if
electoral politics in action is so far
from hypnotic if the conditions of
political competition and governmental
performance under representative
democracy are inevitably frustrating and
the decisions taken usually so faintly
recive any clear stable or firmly
assignable purpose why should it matter
whether or not they are taken under
democracy's auspices there are plainly
circumstances in which it needn't matter
at all if the dimas happens to be
largely of one mind the politicians they
choose or have chosen for them
essentially share their tastes and the
outcomes each favour failed to do net
damage there were there will be little
to defend their choices against the
aegis of democracy will scarcely be in
dispute and few will greatly care
whether it's the known prior choices of
the dimas itself which caused the
politicians to choose as they do where
it does potentially matter is where the
choices at issue are altogether murkier
or the purposes of the politicians
concerned are notably and sharply at
odds with the Jaffna preferences of the
majority of the demos where no one in
question has much comprehension of what
is going on or what is at stake
democracy is as incapacitated as any
other political formula to direct
political choice fairly and for the
better but it's presumptive title to act
still looms through the murk encouraging
a calm and relaxation
which it can do nothing to justify where
the aegis of democracy definitely does
matter greatly is in cases where elected
politicians choose resolutely to defy
the known prior preferences of most of
the demos defy its presumptive Authority
by doing so but still claim its aegis
for the choices they proceed to make
some of those cases can be very clear
and they may have momentous consequences
in Britain's case recently the choice of
its then Prime Minister to join the
United States in invading Iraq
Tony Blair has been eager in many
contexts to claim the mantle of
democracy but if that decision was
compatible with accepting democracy's
authority in directing the action of a
state it's hard to see what decision
could not be if democracy has come to be
the most potent term of authorization in
global political speech it must be a
grave demerit that we have no clear
conception of what it authorizes it is
its potency of course which makes it
both so covetable
and so contentious but it's certainly
not mainly its potency which makes it so
hard to police or to adjudicate the
resulting contention what has made it so
hard to do that is the equivocation now
lodged so deeply within the term itself
that's what I had in mind in picking my
title for these lectures the democratic
maze the maze of contemporary democracy
is a prominent feature of the real
political world in which you and I live
but it's also an immense tissue of words
and that tissue and the world which
enunciates those words are now
adhesively impacted on one another
they've become a single structure a good
maze is one in which it's easy to lose
your bearings and from which once you
have done so it can be very hard to get
out in every real maze there must be at
least one way to get out the route by
which you have come in plainly we can't
escape the maze of contemporary
democracy by retracing our steps we
can't reverse time and we emphatically
don't want to return to any ancien
régime we also can't hope to remove the
myriad other sources of confusion in the
political world we inhabit by
recognizing the route we followed to get
where we now are but what we could
reasonably hope to do is to break the
hypnotic spell which the term democracy
now casts by recognizing how it casts
that spell it is by any human standards
simply ridiculous to have ended up with
a single term for judging where we are
in the politics of the world and what to
value and strive for within those
politics which carries such pretension
to Authority but also equivocate so
uncontrollably between the official
regime name for particular States as
these actually are and the most
appropriate basis for deciding the most
important decisions which bear on the
life chances of human beings across the
globe
you can certainly question whether
democracy has proved a good choice for
picking out either of those domains but
what you cannot reasonably defend is the
judgment that anything at all could
prove a good choice for picking out both
at once I've yet to be persuaded myself
that any single terminal concept would
be a good candidate for picking out the
second for how if the human race should
collectively decide its fate though
justice and utility of each had good
runs for their money if democracy is a
form of government an institutional
structure at a minimum for determining
and implementing the direction of
legitimate coercion within a given
territory and over a given population it
will certainly have no reliable ties to
either justice or utility and there's no
obvious ex-ante reason to expect you to
converge on either more if it succeeds
in getting its way than if it fails to
do so if there was a way to determine
conclusively what should be done by
anyone or everyone to allocate human
life chances across the world that way
would carry Authority against
possible form of government as well as
against every actual government already
loose in the world but there is no such
way and in its absence what we must need
political categories for is to help us
police and strive to direct the
government's we do have to decide an act
less harmfully than they've yet learnt
to in that endless and necessarily
frustrating struggle our democratic maze
it's become extremely urgent to
recognize where democracy as a political
idea can still help us to judge better
and where it can only deepen our
political confusion the core of my
argument is that if we look back
carefully along the route which has led
us here it can still help us to judge
better if we apply it to the structure
and authorization of particular regimes
but can't and won't help us to judge
anything if we insist on conceiving it
as a legitimate or a basis for taking
individual decisions on any but the
smallest scale what to do and avoid
doing in the world depends in
illimitably on the consequences of
acting in one way rather than another
the merits of any way of taking any
particular decision can't be impervious
to its consequences in use it's
certainly a merit of a decision other
things be equal that it be taken on an
appropriate basis and by appropriate
means and the idea of democracy can cast
a little light on what Basie's and means
might be appropriate at least it can
highlight some basis for taking
decisions and some means for reaching
them which are quite clearly
inappropriate I revert momentarily to
the British decision to invade Iraq the
self righteous assurance of an
individual political agent who makes a
decision however elevators and however
popular that earlier points in their
political
career is a very poor candidate for
vindicating the merits of any decision
at all on whatever basis the decision is
taken even if it carries the active
consent of the great majority of a
population it must be a wait year and
more decisive merit that it prove
beneficial in the world in itself I
imagine that's scarcely contentious why
does it matter so much for the political
bearing of democracy's uneasy presence
in the world today principally because
of the intense confusion of our way of
thinking about the politics of the world
in which we live and the alarmingly
ill-conceived character of so much that
we obstinately continue to do it would
be encouraging especially for an
academic to believe that the second of
those grants dismaying collective
fecklessness on the scale of individual
states massively compounded by the
interactions between states within an
overwhelmingly opaque global economy was
principally a consequence of the first
the confusion of the way we think
but that alas is not so it might even be
true that there was no connection
whatever between the confusion of our
thought processes and the in felicity of
our cumulative interactions but there's
every reason to doubt that that's true
either
and it's certainly more within our reach
to diminish the confusion of our own
thought processes than to bring the
unintended consequences of our own
actions under firm intentional control
let alone to do so with the consequences
evident Jung intended by anyone at all
of our cumulative interactions with one
another on the scale of the entire globe
many aspects of that predicament in
which we find ourselves are highly
intractable there are reasons why game
theory has come to loom so large in a
political science education and
collective action
is an inherently puzzling project it's
also still true and very blatantly so
that much of our current predicament
still comes less from being unable to
see what to do them from being reluctant
to do it but over and above the dilemmas
of collective action and our deep-seated
preference for short-term comfort and
convenience over long term security and
flourishing one of the elements which
principally reconciles us to that
unhappy morass is the pseudo Democratic
provenance of so much of it the
reluctance to make our lives less
comfortable and convenient pander to
with indefatigable ingenuity and
assiduity throughout the organization of
our economic life isn't a feature of
human preference which we shall modify
readily and it may require a rather
drastic passage of further evolution
unlikely to eventuate in time to modify
it at all but what might still alter our
current weightings is a somewhat better
apprehension of the magnitude of the
risks were choosing to run and the
brevity of the time scale over which
we've so far elected to run them that's
why the subject I've been trying to
bring into focus doesn't merely pick out
something intellectually embarrassing
even for the providers and beneficiaries
of the most impressive education now on
offer in the world it also brings out
something politically and hence now
biologically disastrous you can think of
what it picks out as the pseudo
Democratic authorization of the huge
bulk of overt public decisions in the
world which even purport to carry
Democratic authorization and the
unremittingly pseudo Democratic
authorization of the entire structure of
covet or inadvertent decision and non
decision within which those over
since rest as it's used to refer even to
overt public decisions in our world the
predication of democracy is to an
overwhelming degree sedative and dis
informative to block that narcotic
impact and restore some clarity at least
at the level of authorization to what is
going on we should we would have to
relearn our verbal habits and
reconstruct our thinking quite fiercely
as I see it that pseudo Democratic
provenance rests on nothing more robust
than a feeble Pung there are criteria
for decisions being democratic but those
criteria quite evident evidently don't
apply even to the vast majority of over
public decisions in the United States of
America and it's hard to see how they
could be thought to apply to cover
decisions or inadvertent decisions
anywhere at all to block the narcotic
impact of pseudo Democratic
authorization of almost everything which
the United States or any of its
contemporary counterparts does as a
state it would be necessary to recognize
that democracy can't plausibly be
predicated of particular decisions at
all except under conditions so
restrictive that they can scarcely be
inserted into the ongoing life of a
state if we did choose to deploy the
Democratic predicate more parsimoniously
in that way as we certainly could though
I'm as confident as you are that we
won't
we could certainly position ourselves to
think more clearly about the challenges
which confront us and the resources we
have to meet them we could also at least
hope to retain on a coherent basis the
conviction that the states of which most
of us are citizens and this one most
prominently of all are authorized and
possessed governments which have been
authorized
in a way an innocence in which the
citizens of China and the bandit kingdom
of Libya still discernibly aren't but
even that conviction needs to be stated
with greater care to be at all solid in
my first lecture more by assertion and
argument I insisted the democratic
states like every other state viewed
themselves as authorized well beyond any
identifiable warrant for doing so as
Hobbes helpfully explained several
centuries ago that claim is one which a
state must make if it's to furnish the
services which give it its Ray's on - it
has to be free and empowered to decide
and it has to be entitled within some
internal system of self understanding to
enforce what it does decide but that's a
political principle not an epistemic
inference it says nothing whatever about
the prospective merits of the decision
in question on Hobbes his own way of
looking at the matter
just the same must be true of the
decisions of what we would think of as a
democratic state even if Hobbes himself
might have viewed the latter with
special suspicion what carries the
authority is the entitlement and
responsibility to decide not the content
of the decisions reached subsequent
thinking including some influential
recent lines of academic thought have
fudged the relation between entitlement
and content to a very hazardous degree
you can see by that matters if you
consider in the context of my second
lecture the question of whether or not
there is greater reason for confidence
in the public decisions of the United
States or India than there is in those
of the People's Republic of China the
latter's decisions under the agency
which currently rules it have often
proved extremely ill-advised and no one
could plausibly claim them to have been
in our sense democratically authorized
they don't emanate from a context of
free public discussion and they're made
and implemented under circumstances
which are sometimes acutely personally
oppressive and where there's oppressed
have no credible hope of a remedy but
does that necessarily make them and how
far has it actually made them less
felicitous in their public impact that
on the life chances of most of China's
population than the corresponding
decisions of American governments over
the last three decades have proved for
most Americans if or insofar as it has
made them less so what that shares is at
most a weak probability relation between
the ultimate authorization of political
authority and the prospective quality of
particular state decisions I've yet to
see an argument which establishes that
that impact is consistently to the
advantage of democratic states that's
obviously no reason for favoring
autocracy and it does nothing to render
personal oppression less odious but it
is a reason to recognize but nothing
about the presumptively Democratic
provenance of the consequences of public
decision in contemporary democracies can
raise those decisions above suspicion
since democratic governments see and
feel their own authorization with
greater confidence and speak about
achieve anything even more effusive ly
than their more autocratic rivals that
judgment matters and it will matter Tony
Blair comes back into my mind and it
will matter especially whenever the
decisions in question have results which
are unmistakably malign what the
disparities between pretension and
justification reflect in this case is
the far greater
agency of democracy as a paradigm for D
authorizing incumbent power than for
authorizing anything at all
democracy D authorizes incumbency
whenever it rejects particular
incumbents and as we've just seen once
again it can do so every bit as
incisively on the streets as through the
ballot box what it can't ever do with
comparable conclusiveness
is authorize particular holders of power
and what it can virtually never do is
authorize particular state decisions
unless the parameters of those
luminously clear and can be putted in
that form to a dimas genuinely equipped
to understand them and how often to
those circumstances obtain it's
especially implausible to see iterative
mass suffrage elections even under
conditions of uncoerced participation
and unconstrained and effectively
equalized opportunity for the citizens
to communicate with one another and
inform themselves which are as yet are
met in any modern state as authorizing
the particular decisions their Victor's
proceeded to make I've tried to argue
three things that we need to learn to
understand democracy very differently to
see it more clearly hear it with less
and self-congratulatory
ears recognized more accurately where
it's real potency comes from and face up
to the limits of its capacity to direct
our political purposes to do that I've
argued that we now need to take in the
historical process which is inserted
democracy so prominently into the way we
see and feel politics and struggle to
understand it more hazardously and
ambitiously i've argued further that our
cumulative effect failure to do any of
those things itself gravely aggravates
many of the worst dangers which now very
evidently Menace us as a species we need
to find a way out of the maze
which democracy has become for us and
face the awesome decisions which lie
ahead for us as directly and lucidly as
we can that need is constantly rising in
urgency but it doesn't rise at the same
steady pace in the last three months the
pace at which it rises has accelerated
dramatically as a result of two massive
events one obtrusively human in origin
and stretching out by now from Morocco
to the Persian Gulf the other as
brutally extra human as natural
processes come and concentrated in its
impact on the northern island of Japan
both events will have huge and lasting
political consequences the shape of
which we can as yet barely guess at each
shows something fundamental about the
constituents of the Democratic maze the
popular uprisings ripping out across the
arabic-speaking world have demonstrated
once again an unforgettably the
charismatic force of democracy indy
authorizing incumbent rulers and regimes
the bravery and stereo sysm with which
Japan's people have responded to the
habit which has overwhelmed them was
there long before any of their ancestors
had heard the term democracy but even
that deep cultural and social strength
is wilting painfully before the profound
failure to organize the material
foundations of their lives on a safe and
accountable basis which their deeply
entrenched local interpretation of
democracy has shown up under this
savagely extra human pressure you could
put that down to the weakness of that
realization of democracy it's unusually
insulated parochial self-serving and
gymnastic career politics media and the
latter's continuing subordination
to a bureaucratic state apparatus which
long preceded it and which is still
authorized from most citizens point of
view on far more archaic lines but that
media merely expresses more blatantly
elements which are central to the career
politics of every existing
representative democracy and the deep
failure of Japan's state in its
bureaucratic as much as its democratic
aspects was essentially cognitive its
abject failure to recognize and provide
for the scale of risks it's chosen to
run even on the Democratic side that
failure is better seen as an index of
the cowardice and impotence of the media
of professional politics than of any
improper potency set over against the
rest of the population you don't need to
be powerful to remain comfortably
corrupt but you do need power to take
and implement costly decisions for which
most of us will always remain acquit
acutely reluctant to recognize the
necessity it's been some time since any
Japanese government had power of that
kind the blood-stained sounds of Libya
are a vivid symbol of democracy's power
and vulnerability as an orientation
political category bringing down a
tyrannical regime by breaking its
imagined Authority once and for all is
an elating political experience but it
carries little or none of the distance
towards rebuilding a new a regime with a
fresh imaginative Authority of its own
to watch the violent re-imposition of
autocratic rule on even part of a people
which is escape it can be a rending
experience since by then the resulting
struggle can only take the form of a
civil war
civil wars as America knows all too well
have no real victors there they
certainly have losers
seeing clearly democracy can't provide a
license to enter other people's civil
wars even on the side of those who claim
it's mantle though it offers more excuse
for doing so than it could for starting
a civil war which it has no means to
bring to an end such slender licenses
there is to intervene in Libya comes not
from the claims of democracy but from
the duty to try insofar as any of us can
to protect fellow human beings from
being murdered in very large numbers
that Duty requires the capacity to
provide the protection which we mainly
improve not to possess anywhere on the
basis of current political choice and
where it does apply it does so just as
much if those were being gunned down or
hacked to pieces or friends of the
avenging autocrats or of their or of
their Democratic challengers it can't
rest on prior political preference the
more haunting symbol of democracy's
current disorientation is the ruined
cooling towers of Fukushima in Fukushima
for the moment more vividly and concrete
here than anywhere else on earth we can
see how urgently we need to reconsider
and re-engineer the entire causal web
within which our species now lives we
can see how extraordinarily difficult it
is to understand that web and how
baffling it's bound to prove to work out
together what we now need to do in and
to and with it and decide as we do so
how to assign the costs of doing it once
we focus on that we can readily see how
epically unsuited to addressing any of
those tasks the political regimes we
fashioned under democracy's Aegis now
are the anguish of Libya
and our scanty and clumsy instruments
for attempting to Olay it a certainly
something to dwell on but they aren't
the only thing too well-armed now even
in one of Democracies darkest ARS it's
every bit as urgent to recognize where
the political institutions we've
inherited are now failing us and we are
failing ourselves and our descendants in
failing to grasp how and why they are
doing so and how much of what is causing
them to do so has infiltrated and taken
over our habits of thinking speaking and
feeling about politics the Democratic
maze is part of the world or right but
it's also and primarily the assemblage
of those habits since we can't escape
the world itself and since so many of
those habits confine and impede us in
handling its challenges we do dolly need
to reach out beyond them to less
narcissistic and parochial forms of
understanding which can equip us to do
better but how to do so that's a task
above all for the world's great
universities since it's their if
anywhere that humans now gather in
substantial numbers with time to
consider those questions carefully the
freedom to consider them frankly and the
ability to begin to understand them less
abject lis as they really are
almost every distinct aspect may already
be the focus of deep and disciplined
inquiry in institutions well focused for
the purpose but it's wrong to view them
sin optically as just a static some of
those distinct aspects what they are is
a single highly unstable process in
which all of those aspects act
incessantly upon one another amongst
those aspects the contribution of
politics is both
especially hard to grasp and quite
evidently strategically central as yet
the discipline of political science has
had little success in showing how to
grasp its contribution to that process
and it's made no discernable
contribution to showing how to respond
to it under the scientistic epistemic
rubric which increasingly dominates the
profession in North America it's
virtually precluded from trying to view
its own optically and can only
discourage its more responsive pupils
from even trying to view it that way it
can certainly cast ample lights in
detail on why things are unlikely to get
better in a hurry but on how to cause
them to do so it is virtually sworn to a
lofty and self-righteous silence who is
to educate the educators is quite an old
political question on the free
translation one of the oldest political
questions of which were still aware it's
a mistake about the nature of democracy
to suppose that it's any less urgent to
question in a democracy and a mistake
about the gravity of our present
ecological and political predicament not
to recognize how awesomely that
predicament raises its urgency now
whatever else a great university
achieves today and for all its dazzling
variety and accumulated prowess it
should send every one of its pupils out
into the world at least understanding
that the core of my case over these four
lectures is quite simple it's that the
global ascent of democracy as a vehicle
of presumptive legitimacy once we
recognize how and why it has occurred
has done as yet as much to aggravate
that predicament as it has to alleviate
it and that it's a pressing civic
responsibility for all of us in a
peremptory professional responsibility
the political scientists input
to pull the veil of democracy off that
predicament and help steady us all to
judge what we must now do in face of the
inexorably structured chaos which we've
made together